- [Interviewer] All right, Bonafide.
- Hi Mark.
- [Interviewer] Welcome back.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] It's
great to see you again.
You look fantastic.
- Thank you.
I'm trying.
- [Interviewer] So, what's going on?
It's been quite a while
since we were together here.
- Well, you know, I mean,
since the last video
where I said that I had wanted to be at
before August of this year, you know.
It's been a struggle.
I'm not quite sure why
it's been a struggle, but..
Well, no, I don't want
to say the word "but".
99% of the time, everything
after "but" is bullshit.
- [Interviewer] It's been a
hard year for everybody, though.
- Hell, to each his own.
However, since I came last time,
I've been having so many issues.
So many, it's beginning to
get discomforting to me.
You know, if I had to
really, really, really,
really really look at the man,
that's finna stop for me on them streets,
and some of the good ones
are even bad now, you know?
I had a man pull me over to
the side of the train track.
He was old, he was older,
you know what I'm saying?
You know, half breathing, or whatever.
He pulled me over, and he
pulled out this flashlight.
He was like, well, I'm just
going to tell you what it is.
I'ma tase you, put you
out, because some ho
done robbed my homeboys, or whatever,
and I'm finna tase you, let you go down
so they can come and see who you is,
and we can all fuck you.
You know, and it's like..
- [Interviewer] When did this happen?
- About a week ago.
- [Interviewer] I mean,
the guys that are out here
picking girls up, I mean,
they seem like they're insane.
- They are.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
I mean, maybe they have
mental problems, too.
Maybe they have low self-esteem, too.
I don't know what they're going through.
Probably the corona virus, I don't know.
You know what I'm saying?
Everybody getting greedy.
Everybody out there want to
rob hoes and mislead a bitch.
But I feel like we should
all be a community.
We in the same game.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, no, it seems to me,
I've mentioned this a
lot in some of the talks
with girls that work
the street, it's just,
it seems evident that that
everyone's out for themselves.
The tricks are-
- Right, right.
- [Interviewer] Tricks
want what they want.
The pimps want what they want.
The girls are all, like, in
competition against each other.
Everybody's-
- Right, and it's like-
- [Interviewer] The cops even.
- It's bitches, we struggling,
you know what I'm saying?
And we can't even come together
and keep a room together.
You know, shit, the magic carpet
they got upstairs,
downstairs, jacuzzi room.
Shit, at least we have that.
You know what I'm saying?
But it's not that type of party no more.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it's a rough life.
- They stealing, even the hoes
stealing from hoes right now.
And it's ridiculous.
You know, my knees weren't
like this the last time.
You know what I'm saying?
I done had it rough.
You know, I'm just strong.
I'm acrobatic.
And I've been maneuvering
my way out of some shit.
But man.
- [Interviewer] You're a survivor.
I got fresh wounds that ain't right.
You know what I'm saying?
For dumb shit.
And it's ridiculous out there right now.
Right now.
You know?
I mean, as of last night, it's ridiculous.
You know, if I didn't
maintain my regulars,
or some of my regulars, or whatever
because I done switched
phones like 90 going North
because I be around my ho
partners and lose my phone.
I get my phone stolen.
That's what I mean, ain't
nobody out for nobody.
Why would you take my phone?
I need my..
You never know what I got to do.
I done had six phones stolen
in the last past three months.
That ain't right.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- It's a dangerous game.
Shit, I'm trying to call
Chris's and get me a job.
I don't give a shit.
I don't give a damn, cause this ain't it.
You know, I'm telling
anybody that's looking
at this video, this shit ain't it.
- [Interviewer] (laughs) No,
I'm surprised that anybody
gets into this line of work.
- Yeah, but don't get me wrong,
it's fun as fuck at times.
- [Interviewer] But what's the attraction?
- For me?
- [Interviewer] For anybody.
A lot of girls are doing it.
- I mean, but there's so
many different point of views
of attractions, because I noticed lately
because my daughter just
done hit the ho stroll.
How can I say anything?
I've never raised her.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Right, but she's been on the ho stroll.
I been looking for her.
Last time, I think, I shot the video,
I think I was looking for my daughter.
I think I mentioned that.
Right, so anyway, she's been found.
- [Interviewer] She's how old?
- You know what I'm saying?
She hoing 90 going North.
- [Interviewer] How old is she?
- You know, she got a pimp.
She 16, we just had her 16th birthday.
But I didn't know she was doing
the things that she's doing.
However, it made me
get a different outlook
on this shit real quick.
Because it's a different..
Even though I never raised my baby.
Even though she was adopted
to my auntie and uncle.
To see something that came from me,
even though I didn't
care then, I care now.
I don't want to be standing
on the motherfucking corner
on long beach at west end in the sixties
and see my daughter.
That'd tear me down,
I ain't gonna have
nothing else to live for.
- [Interviewer] But what's the attraction?
- Well, my attraction,
the attraction that she said is for her.
It's because she got
this nigga that love her.
That she think that love her.
Cause she..
- [Interviewer] Who's just a gang member,
that's figured out that
he can hustle girls.
- That's preying like a pimp.
You know, and that's what they call it.
Gorilla pimping.
Tennis shoe pimping.
They want to stand on your
heels and all that bullshit,
while they do what they do.
Why you do what you do?
I don't know how the fuck
you can catch a date anyway.
Your mind ain't even COVID steady.
You can't even be a happy ho.
They made it up.
'Cause you too busy trying to worry about,
you know, what time to go
in, how much to charge.
Cause I remember, when
I was working for a PR.
I usually worry about did
I call it the right time?
Did I do this?
Did I come in at the right time?
Did I make enough?
Did I make my whole quarter?
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] You've had how many pimps?
- Oh, I have four.
I had four pimps before.
I was a choosy ho.
Because if it ain't right
here, I'm going to the next.
- [Interviewer] So, the
way a girl leaves one pimp
and goes to another is she chooses?
- Oh, she would have to.
- [Interviewer] And then
does she have to pay?
- She would have to.
I wouldn't give a fuck
if it's at gunpoint.
You have to make the choice.
She would have to choose.
- [Interviewer] But if
you're leaving one pimp to go
to another one, you have
to make some transaction?
- I mean, shit, why wouldn't you?
- [Interviewer] Well, it
probably depends on the pimp.
- If you want that motherfucking pimp,
why wouldn't you go there and put..
Hold on, excuse me, I got
2,500 on me right now.
I'm trying to choose your team.
It ain't like that no more, though.
- [Interviewer] How is it now?
- It ain't like that.
That's how it used to be.
You know what I'm saying?
That's real motherfucking be on it.
Yeah, it's not like that no more.
We don't even walk on the
yellow brick line no more.
I mean, in the middle of the street.
We don't even walk the
yellow brick line no more.
We to busy chasing.
Running across the
street, running this way,
loving the lime light and all that shit.
And ain't getting shit.
- [Interviewer] Are the
girls free to leave now?
- Are they free to leave?
Them bitches is running.
I don't even know how they there.
They running too much.
They on their phone too much.
You can't even look at traffic.
Cause you on your phone with your pa.
You can't even pay
attention to what the fuck
you doing to get off of it.
To get out of it.
Cause you're too busy
worried about how he feel,
how you feel.
I done seen so many bitches
walk down the ho stroll
with motherfucking frowns on their face
and all that bullshit, in the
last past month and a half.
It's ridiculous.
Bitch, put a smile on your face.
Happy hoes make dough.
- I mean, shit, because if you mad at him
because last night and it's last night,
you can't get last night back, bitch.
Come on in to today.
It's like, damn.
As soon as I get up Mark,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm that bitch hide my money
in a motherfucking hole
on the ground.
I don't give a damn.
Because I don't know who around me.
Everybody else seems
like they got alien DNA,
and they human.
Humans with alien DNA.
- [Interviewer] And drugs
are still a big part of it?
- I mean, shit, they can be,
but I don't smoke when I'm
on the ho stroll.
Nothing but a nicotine cigarette.
Drink a sip.
At 2-11, still reserved so
I can stay on the curve.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean, shit.
Somehow you gotta be
altercated, I don't give a damn.
If you altercated through a dick.
If you altercated through drugs.
If you're altercated through alcohol.
Either you altercated through motivation.
I wouldn't give a damn what.
You going to be altercated on something.
Your addiction going to be something.
I don't give a damn.
Even if it's making the
next motherfucker feel good.
Because you don't know who you is.
- [Interviewer] It's gotten
to be more dangerous.
- That was my major part.
That was my major part of my problem
is trying to satisfy
the next motherfucker.
For what?
I ain't even satisfied myself.
You know, I used to be riding
dick and all that shit,
trying to get a motherfucker off and shit.
Bitch, you forgot about you.
- [Interviewer] But
like a lot of the Johns
want to do it without a condom
now. And I hear all kinds of-
- I mean, it's a lot of them.
They want to do it without
a condom, but it's ways.
You know, I done had a
couple of them pull over
and say they want some head.
Okay, without a condom?
Okay, I got you.
Don't worry about nothing
because I put my condom
on with my mouth anyway.
So, how would you even know
it's there until it's done?
You know what I'm saying?
I mean, it's hoes that
ain't been schooled right.
'Cause that Johns that
want to do without a condom
been going on way back then.
And it ain't happened.
The bullshit that they doing,
the bullshit that motherfuckers
is deciding to do now
it's just called strawberrying.
You know what I'm saying?
Cherrying it.
- [Interviewer] What does that mean?
- Motherfuckers is coming up talking 'bout
they want a bitch to
lick their ass, and shit.
You know what I'm saying?
Make sure you have your diddle damn ready.
I'm ready.
I'll lick that motherfucker.
Finna get into the grind.
Make sure you ready.
My granny just died from HIV.
My mama suffering from HIV.
Why in the fuck?
Not me.
My name Bonafide anyway.
So I don't have that problem.
You know, it's called being
official with whatever you do.
Do your best at whatever you do.
Have a goal for whatever the fuck you do,
'cause if you ain't
doing it with no purpose
then what is it good for?
Absolutely nothing.
That's how I came on here.
I had a roof over my head.
Right now I'm struggling
with no roof over my head.
Mobile home burned down.
I don't even know how the
mobile home get burned down.
I done had a heart attack since then.
- [Interviewer] You had a heart attack?
- You know what I'm saying?
Stress will do that to you.
Drugs included.
Alcohol included.
You know what I'm saying?
Experimental drugs included.
Experimental drugs, when I say that,
I'm talking about wet daddy, shurm,
you know what I'm saying?
All that bullshit.
And Christina, you know what I'm saying?
Them chemically made drugs.
But herb that keep me slow, so I can't.
No way.
Anyways, Mark, today, I came to say,
if I've been doing the
same thing this long
and having elevated,
or every time I elevate
I allow somebody in to shackle
my feet and let me down.
Then I'm doing the wrong thing.
I feel like now that
I'm doing the same thing
and expecting different results,
like I can master this shit.
I got 36 regulars.
I ain't mastered shit.
You know, but how to
get to the next paper.
How to get the next bread.
How to get the next dough.
Without a lie.
Without lying to get
some motherfucking bread.
Without stealing to get
'Cause I ain't finna look
over my back for nothing.
I'm not going to catch whiplash.
Whiplash ain't for me.
If it's your money, you can have it.
If you give it to me, then it's my money
and you ain't going to get it back.
You know, I just, I don't shuck and jive.
And I feel like this,
all you women out there
that's robbing these
tricks and all that shit,
just two weeks ago, I suffered from it.
I almost got dragged and killed.
If I didn't let go the bumper
of that motherfucking car,
I'd be assed out.
It ain't worth it, if a
motherfucker didn't give it to you,
it ain't for you.
All you little motherfuckers
out there that's
trying to be this shit right here,
look at the frowns on
a motherfucker's face.
And you'll realize that it ain't for you.
Get another job.
That's all I got to say.
- [Interviewer] All right, Bonafide.
Thank you so much for coming in again.
I wish you the best of luck
down through the hard times.